so uh
what are we even doing we're gonna
examine some asynchronous primitives in
javascript uh with callbacks we're gonna
take a look at more modern approaches
like promises and async await
we're gonna take a look at purescript
abstractions in the effect and afmonad
we're going to learn just a little bit
about fibers which are almost threads
so
examples one through three we're going
to take a look at sort of simple event
emitters
so this is a way to
sort of reason about how
javascript asynchronousy sort of appears
to work so this is
synchronous programming but it can build
up into
an asynchronous kind of api
or
essentially can
be used to sort of reason about the way
that the browser allows us to do
asynchronous programming
or node for that matter so
here we have sort of uh an emitter
object it's got this idea of some
listeners uh which is a queue of
functions that will grow
as we add them with on event so we're
going to add listeners and then we're
going to fire off a listener so this is
where we get into sort of asynchronous
appearing behavior where we can set up
some events that then happen later on so
we can reason about these computations a
little bit differently we can sort of
store some computation elsewhere and
then fire it off but again this is still
synchronous right we could sort of step
through this code
really easily without worrying too much
about missing pieces at least
until we get into things that are out
and stored in different modules where we
we have to reason about things a little
differently
so
this is a really basic uh system let's
go ahead and run this sort of
uh asynchronous
foundation uh so
here we can see we have this idea of
like starting the action listener
attached and then even though we say pow
up here it doesn't happen until we sort
of kick off
this event okay so it's a really simple
sort of uh scaffolding out
of of this um
computation that's gonna happen later on
and then we can kick it off in a much
easier way without defining
all of the computation that's gonna
happen right at the moment when it has
to happen
okay
so next
we're going to move ahead so we'll
extend it and we can actually add we can
add a lot of things to this actually if
we flip ahead we can we can extend it to
include event types which is what we've
done here
but we can also extend to
different types of observable data
and we can extend it to do
all kinds of other things state
management
it's a good intuition for how dom event
listeners uh operate so if you want to
add a button to a page and have events
occur it's it's also
uh sort of how
uh ajax requests and networking requests
are gonna work
so here we have another example we've
got these two different event types and
i've sort of
intentionally switched their order
so now we can we can sort of fire those
off
in in different orders based on labeled
events so our uh what used to be just
one queue is now a map of cues to event
types okay
and then we can have another sort of
version of it where
instead we hold some some data and every
time we we change the data we we make
that data available to some functions uh
for state management okay so this is
observable data
you can see we also optionally give the
ability to reference the
previous value using variatic functions
here um so because we don't have a fixed
number of arguments to our function type
in uh in javascript we're able to to
pull these kinds of tricks uh these will
get ironed out later on but for now
there are some conveniences that we can
pull from this
so
let's go ahead and run that example
and you can see
uh as soon as we change this initial
value of hello
to
bob
we get uh
first the the first listener going off
and and logging out the original value
hello
and then a second listener fires uh
which is going to
give you the
new value
uh so these could be supplying them out
to other callbacks they could be
running um network calls themselves and
you can you can get this notion of
a
sort of a chain of functions that call
each other uh building up a call stack
but potentially with asynchronous steps
where you're not adding things to the
call stack immediately
so uh
this brings us to sort of a fundamental
problem
javascript is single threaded usually
worker threads don't count they're a bit
of a newer addition but what i'm talking
about is the fact that javascript runs
with an event loop and when an event is
triggered there's a call to an event
listener
that's placed in a queue kind of waiting
for the event to resolve and once the
call stack is cleared
of synchronous behaviors the javascript
runtime is going to start to execute
listener calls from the queue
so it's it's sort of very similar to
this but
the reality is that this emitter is uh
obscured it's implemented off in the
browser maybe in c plus plus uh
it's in the node core it's part of the
web apis that you think of as sort of
the javascript base library
all right
um
so uh there's a really great talk on
this that i can never do justice to it's
called what the heck is the event loop
anyway from philip philip roberts and it
essentially goes through just this with
a lot more demonstrations so if you're
interested in knowing a lot more about
how the event loop works i really
recommend that as a great starting place
now uh
there's also some modern abstractions
that have been added on to help us
prevent what's called callback hell this
idea like maybe we have so many
listeners uh and
additionally like the old
syntax for functions was very
big and relatively clunky relative to
these uh
these arrow functions that we're using
so we we came up with promises they're
they're sort of a wrapper for unfinished
computations they can't be cancelled
once once you start them off so here
uh
we're using fetch which is an api for
doing network calls so we're calling off
to this
ai
[Music]
age predictor based on your name
so
there's a difference between this
example and the previous examples here
we could
trace through all the actions and never
lose track of sort of where
the javascript interpreter might be uh
operating and how it might evaluate out
but here we get to a point where we call
fetch and we'll very quickly get
confused because the fetch
computation doesn't wait for us to call
fire on any of these it kicks off
immediately
through a browser api
uh so this returns a promise
here
uh which we then call dot then on uh but
the computation is sort of running in
the background in another thread that we
don't directly control and when that
thread uh completes and and receives its
response
uh this is going to be kicked off and
then likewise this is going to be kicked
off so we have this sort of chain of
events and and if you squint this is
going to look a lot like a monad and you
don't have to squint that hard uh this
actually kicked off as as this api was
being discussed there was a hot debate
about adding uh
features like monad to javascript um
however uh there is some convenience
here because you don't really have to
think about whether you're calling
uh bind or map on this you can return
promises or not promises and that was
determined to be the more sort of
javascript friendly api
um
now we also get some pleasantness that
looks a little bit like do notation so
we get async await uh and if you sort of
equals a weight if you squint that into
an arrow you might imagine this looks
quite a bit like
haskell's 2 notation and you wouldn't be
wrong
the kicker
because it is just like due notation is
async actually denotes that your return
value gets wrapped in a promise so then
you can go ahead and catch for errors
at the end uh just like you might catch
some monad say that has monad catch your
monad throw all right uh
so we we have these sort of
uh functional like
types of expressions where we can
sort of uh
set up chains of computation uh and also
set up uh
binding do notation
uh but like i said it's not cancelable
we haven't officially created monads or
functors in javascript
and this is where
the next great example comes from
because there's this great library
called future
and future
allows you to wrap up promises with a
different type which does implement
monads and functors and bi-functors and
alternative and all kinds of other
abstractions that you might be familiar
with so if you are using javascript and
you cannot use purescript this is a
great system to use
it also has certain api helpers like
enforcing that you supply an error
handler
before you get to unwrap and get your
actual value out
uh you can also set up
uh
cancellation as well so there's a lot of
great things just to get out of the
futures library there's also a way to do
async await like syntax using iterators
so there's a lot of great options for
you with future but the main
problem that you might have
is that flutters errors they're great
type errors but they are at run time
which brings us to purescript
so with purescript we are going to be
talking about three different techniques
the the effect monad uh promises and
their relationship to af
uh as well as uh fibers and we're gonna
be taking a look at some some examples
with fetch and aff jacks
um
so
let's just move over to the examples
uh i've created a couple of simple
wrappers here i've created two wrappers
one is uh it uses the fetch api just so
that we're comparing apples to apples
but this fetch api
it's going to
essentially just uh take a callback and
call our callback so there's not a whole
lot going on here uh
it allows us to just sort of have a a
callback
like uh interface and pure script you'll
also notice there's this uh just nullary
function so we have currying here we get
the url we get a callback and then this
this nullary function is an effect so uh
when you talk about an effect in pure
script we're just talking about a
a lazy
value a function that is deferred okay
now we've also got this one for promises
so this one is going to return uh an
effect with a promise inside
and we can change promises to
uh
to apps and apps to promises uh so we'll
talk a little bit about that uh
purescript has two different types of
effects it used to have many more but
we've mostly gotten rid of them
so there's uh
like we can return just a promise and
say oh we've got the promise but there's
not really great tools for unwrapping a
promise you'll you'll mostly want to use
af unless you're returning it for a
javascript user maybe in a library
so what we've actually got here
we've got first just a callback based
api where we're using our effect call so
we just supply a callback there
let's go ahead and run that
and we get some compiler output and then
we actually get the effect itself
running
and when we get a result we'll get the
callback fired
it's stalling out for me so i'll just
move ahead
so the next thing that we can do
is uh we can set up
an af
so
here we're getting the result
uh
as an af and and what we've done we've
got this fetch function that we've
implemented in peerscript just using a
promise helper to
to unwrap the promise and supply it as
an f
f gives us all of the powers of functors
moment ads bifunctors oh my and it's
cancelable all of the great features of
future
however we're in a purescript context so
we can kind of reason about our types
at compile time rather than at
runtime okay let's go ahead and run that
and there's our output so again we're
just outputting
uh text as things land there's not a
whole lot else going on we're just
calling log
all right
um
so now we've got these sort of basic
examples uh what i wanted to do next was
show
a pure script native example so let me
just come down here this is aftrax um
uncomment the code that runs it so
aftrax is the ajax library for
purescript so
we're returning an app we can do a
native request
this has sort of full type type
safe setup for your request so
here we can do a request with a get
method
a given response format so you might be
anticipating
a string response or a json response or
some other response you can actually set
it up to do some of the parsing for you
if you like
in this case i'm just leaving it as a
string so we're not getting too much
into the parsing world
but it's the same request essentially so
we can run this as well
okay uh so that's sort of the the native
way to approach this there is also a
shortened helper just called get
which allows you to use much less of
this um but that is the the basic idea
of an afjax usage so one thing that
you'll note about aftrax and it's
something that is common across quite a
few peer script libraries is it's
distributed across multiple modules for
typical usage so
i'd say this is sort of a design
principle across purescript is it's very
very modularized so just be prepared for
that that you'll be jumping around all
of the different modules in that library
even compared to haskell it's quite
modular
all right so we talked about fetch we
talked about aftrax i do want to spend
some time
with fibers so fibers are a
really interesting feature fibers
essentially allow you to take afs
and
control these forked computations
so
you can start to reason about f
uh
as a unit of asynchronous computation
but a fiber is really a chain of
asynchronous computations that you could
then call various methods on so you get
some reason about it you can see it like
fork af i think is probably the most
descriptive uh intuitive function that
you might see
coming from haskell because it works
exactly like fork i o so you'll get ids
you'll get
cancellation capabilities
and you can join fibers kill fibers
you can make a fiber invincible
or you can make an f invincible
so there's lots of different uh
capabilities that you can set up
for fibers and for working with complex
asynchronous computations
all right
so
just to summarize pure purescript's
approach to asynchronous computations
you get
lots of different
typesafe wrappers to define the outputs
of unfinished computations
and you also get control over
synchronicity and asynchronicity using
effect and af so effect is for all
synchronous effects which is why you
have to supply callbacks everywhere and
f is for asynchronous effects so you
don't have to think about supplying
callbacks you can just operate on your
data without too much concern about what
is
synchronous or asynchronous although it
is clear
uh in your
notation which one is which because
we're in due notation
uh you also get type level knowledge of
blocking operations which is sort of i
guess the cholera to the above
uh you get abstractions for chains of
computations which follows uh familiar
type class interfaces and laws
uh and you get the flexibility of
futures but at compile time and you
could do notation
so let's go take a look at a production
example i want to show you a library
that i've been working on uh we're
pulling in a bunch of websocket things
we're using the ws library in javascript
so we've pulled in a bunch of foreign
imports which are just wrappers around
various library calls
and
what we can set up
through a whole bunch
uh layers around the specific websocket
interface that we're using
is this uh
this query m monad
which allows us to just have a reader t
over some config
and
this essentially allows us to
set up some guarantees through uh adding
and removing listeners
uh
sort of all over the place uh as queries
go out and come back to abstract over
the fact that websockets don't give you
good request response guarantees
and so
this sort of builds up a dynamic
dispatch system so you can see it we do
quite a bit here to build up a type safe
dynamic dispatch system we build up
listener sets and methods for adding and
removing to a listener set
but through this system we actually have
a very nice api for working with
websockets where you don't have to
concern yourself with a like a mother
listener that listens for everything
that this websocket could possibly spit
out
we have it but we have it sort of buried
in some async helpers
and we can abstract over it so this is a
really really uh strong use of the
afmond ad i think in in purescript i
encourage you to take a close look at
this
this is the cardano browser tx library
on the plutonomicons this is one that
i've worked on with the team at mlabs
well
that's